foreign
[Music]
can you drive me today are you ready to
go now yeah just give me like five
seconds
[Music]
by that logic we should just occupy
every Country Joe I agree with you Lila
thank you Ziggy how do you agree with
Lila oh [ __ ] excuse my brain for knowing
what not to say
I know it'll get better
cats thanks for tuning in
Mom did you open my doorbells [ __ ] sorry
did you try to open the door while I was
live streaming what's live streaming
that's where I have 20 000 followers and
I'm validated and I'm starred which is
Terror hard to get just make sure you
don't play the blues what white people
playing blues music is cultural
appropriation I play classic folk rock
with alternative influences I don't know
what that means
and then you called the police I called
them you're in the right place you're
safe and you'll have two events for as
long as you need he's my little knight
in shining armor it's true kids are just
pure love you know what I mean
what the hell are you doing installing a
red Beacon right so people know when I'm
live streaming and by people I mean you
Ziggy you don't have to be interested in
politics you think I'm stupid no no I
didn't say that I brought you this hat
Kyle it was my sons but he no longer
wears it I don't know what he wears
anymore
[Music]
yes boys your age can't bring themselves
to be kind and you can't help yourself
you're a special person
are you happy I think so why are you
asking me as I'm reading this article
about teen suicide and it's highest in
your age group okay thanks
Mom's home
when you're a little boy you're my
little Ally your life is going to be
happier you're gonna be one of the good
ones and then something switched in you
you stopped being interested in anything
outside your own little world
can you take me to school are you ready
to go right now I'm right here dude
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]